how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival but how do
I get in yes there are negative that
race can involve and you can try to
change language in order to get people
thinking about those negative
conceptions and new ways but something
that I've often said and I just stole it
from Steve Pinker is something called
the euphemism treadmill which is that
thought has a way of catching up with
language and destroying whatever you
were trying to do and so the process
that you're talking about Stanley it
stream that you can start thinking about
things in a new way when you give
something a new label but the label is
generally gonna wear out and the thought
changes more slowly than the language
and so for example - I'm gonna pick
something at random home relief if you
were talking to somebody in 1950 who
with a mother at home with children and
the government gives gets her money to
take care of the children that was
called home relief and if you think
about that's a very nice term after
about 15 years people were spitting out
the word home relief and almost sounded
like you know Roach poison or something
and so that changes to welfare yes
that's five in mid 60s and nowadays in
terms of the way welfare is discussed
you have to work to think what a warm
word that is welfare but then it became
welfare and so now what a cash
assistance is the way when it's taught
to talk about it that now sounds kind of
blank given about fifteen years and
they're doing the same thing the certain
feelings about government assistance in
some quarters persists and so until the
thoughts change the language the way I
think of it as yes change the language
because it does
people thinking but realize that each
term is only going to last for about
twenty years and so for example you were
a negro and their associations change it
to black okay
then somebody decided in 1989 I never
quite understood it that it's supposed
to be african-american that's now rather
worn out and I've heard that some people
are now going back to black I'm one of
them because I like that that was fine
we're gonna have to keep changing it
until the negative perceptions erode
sometimes those changes are in fact
planned and planned by forces that we
might not admire I woke up one morning
to realize that the word gambling and
disappeared in relation to casinos and
other it's gaming gaming and you think
well yes it's a game and everyone likes
games and all of the association's that
with gambling of crime and the
destruction of cities etc all of which
are absolutely true all of those
associations will put aside by the word
gaming so I want i've never investigated
this i wonder was there a high-level
conference of lovely casino owners
perhaps including Donald Trump a boy who
got into a room somewhere in Atlantic
City where there were in the end many
rooms vacant so they they say let's do
gaming let's substitute gaming for
gambling there's a Republican strategist
by the name of monks there was a master
like this Frank Frank Luntz who you know
turned oil drilling into fuel discovery
if things like that all the time and
they work so they're so that the Roaring
advice of changing language which he of
course issued from the perspective of a
good-hearted
a century liberal he thought it would be
a good way to solve our problems it can
also be a good way it could also be a
good way to eliminate things that
certain speakers don't want and that
brings me back to ops all of us here
share share interests in Hobbs Hobbs
begins his discussion of speech in the
Leviathan by saying it is speech which
distinguishes us from the animals
something he would have read in
Aristotle's politics and elsewhere and
he explains out therefore we were able
to make proposals I were able to plan
how we're able to have community
projects etc all because of speech about
50 or 60 pages later it returns to
speech and explain time and I'm just
bumbling it's like a hundred pages it
returns to the topic and he says but of
course speech also is the cause of all
our evils because speech is what allows
us to deceive our wives and husbands it
allows us to act in counterfeit ways in
business transactions if it weren't
allows nations to betray other nations
these two narratives about speech that
in its productive of capabilities and
capacities of animals don't have and
then is the seed of possible destruction
of both truth that's what we're dealing
with all the time get your tickets for
the world's largest music and philosophy
festival how the light gets in dog